SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN, I'LL RODA-GIL ARCHULETA.
ASHBY. ATKINS. BECKER. BLAKE
SPEER. BRADFORD. CABALLERO.
CORTEZ. DALY DODD. DURAZZO.
EGGMAN. GLASER GONZALEZ. GROVE.
HURTADO. JONES LAIRD. LIMÓN.
MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR MIN. NEWMAN.
NGUYEN. NILO OCHOA. PORTANTINO.
ROTH RUBIO. SATO. SKINNER.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS STERN. UMBERG.
WAHAB. WIENER. WILK MEMBERS A
QUORUM IS PRESENT. WHAT OUR
MEMBERS AND OUR GUESTS. BEYOND
THE RAIL AND IN THE GALLERY.
PLEASE RISE. WE'LL BE LED IN
PRAYER TODAY BY OUR CHAPLAIN,
SISTER MICHELLE GORMAN. AFTER
WHICH WE'RE GOING TO ASK YOU TO
REMAIN STANDING FOR THE PLEDGE
OF ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
SISTER GORMAN. LET US LET US
CENTER OURSELVES IN GOD'S
PRESENCE. IF YOU WISH TO DRAW
NEAR TO GOD. THE SUFI POET ABU
SAYEED TELLS US HOW, IF YOU WISH
TO DRAW NEAR TO GOD, SEE GOD IN
THE HEARTS AROUND YOU. SPEAK
WELL OF ALL PRESENT OR ABSENT.
IF YOU WOULD BE A LIGHT FOR
OTHERS, BE LIKE THE SUN. SHOW
THE SAME FACE TO ALL, TO BRING
JOY TO A SINGLE HEART IS BETTER
THAN BUILDING COUNTLESS SHRINES
FOR WORSHIP. TO CAPTURE ONE
HEART THROUGH KINDNESS IS BETTER
THAN SETTING A THOUSAND FREE.
THIS IS THE TRUE LOVER OF GOD
WHO LIVES WITH OTHERS, RISES AND
EATS AND SLEEPS LIKE OTHERS,
GIVES AND TAKES IN THE BAZAAR,
YET NEVER FORGETS GOD, EVEN FOR
A MOMENT. AND ON THIS 80TH
ANNIVERSARY OF D-DAY, GRACIOUS
GOD, FILL US WITH YOUR JOY AS WE
CONTINUE TO GROW CLOSER TO YOU
AND WORK FOR PEACE IN OUR WORLD.
AMEN. MEMBERS, PLEASE JOIN ME IN
THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO THE
FLAG. FOR WHICH IT STANDS. ONE
NATION UNDER GOD, INDIVISIBLE,
WITH LIBERTY AND JUSTICE FOR ALL
. MEMBERS TODAY MARKS THE 80TH
ANNIVERSARY OF D-DAY. SO I'M
GOING TO ASK THAT ALL MEMBERS
FOR A MOMENT OF SILENCE, IN
REMEMBRANCE OF THE BRAVE
INDIVIDUALS WHO LOST THEIR LIFE
ON THAT HISTORIC, IMPACTFUL DAY
HERE IN AMERICA AND ACROSS THE
WORLD.
THANK YOU. MEMBERS. NOW WE'RE
MOVING TO PRIVILEGES OF THE
FLOOR. I WANT TO RECOGNIZE BOTH
SENATOR SKINNER AND SENATOR
ATKINS. SENATOR SKINNER, ARE YOU
PREPARED? MR. PRESIDENT, I AM
MEMBERS. THANK YOU, THE SENATOR
FROM SAN DIEGO. AND I RISE TODAY
TO INTRODUCE AND PRESENT SENATE
RESOLUTIONS TO FIVE INDIVIDUALS
WHO HAVE BEEN INSTRUMENTAL IN
SUPPORTING POLICIES TO ADDRESS
THE EXTREME DISPARITIES IN THE
ALLOCATION OF VENTURE CAPITAL.
NOW, WHY IS THAT RELEVANT?
BECAUSE, AS WE KNOW, CALIFORNIA
HAS WE'RE THE FIFTH LARGEST
ECONOMY IN THE WORLD. WE ARE THE
INNOVATION ECONOMY AND VENTURE
FUNDS ARE MUCH WHAT FUELED THAT.
AND SO IF YOU ARE ONE OF THE
ENTREPRENEURS OR INNOVATORS WHO
WANT TO ADD TO THIS INNOVATION
ECONOMY, AND YET YOU ARE
EXCLUDED FROM SUCH SOURCES OF
CAPITAL, THEN OFTEN THAT THAT
EXCELLENT ECONOMIC ACTIVITY THAT
WE COULD ALL BENEFIT FROM IS
EXCLUDED. ADDITIONALLY SO FIRST
UP, I WANT TO INTRODUCE TRACY
WARREN, WHO IS THE FOUNDER OF
THE F FIVE COLLECTIVE. THE F
FIVE COLLECTIVE IS A PIONEERING
WOMAN LED INVESTMENT FIRM THAT
IS COMMITTED TO CATALYZING
GENERATIONAL CHANGE FOR 1
BILLION WOMEN WORLDWIDE. MISS
WARREN IS PASSIONATE ABOUT
ELEVATING THE INVESTMENT
OPPORTUNITIES THAT EXIST FROM
BACKING EXCEPTIONAL WOMEN
FOUNDED VENTURES WITH AN
AMBITION, EXCUSE ME, WITH AN
AMBITIOUS MISSION TO FUND 1000
FEMALE FOUNDERS BY 2030, MISS
WARREN AND HER COLLEAGUES AT THE
F FIVE COLLECTIVE ARE DEDICATED
TO CLOSING THE GENDER FUNDING
GAP AND PAVING THE WAY FOR A
MORE INCLUSIVE AND EQUITABLE
FUTURE. RIGHT. ONE. THEY
PROBABLY HAVE THEM IN ORDER.
CONGRATULATIONS. NEXT UP IS
MARQUESA FINCH. SOME OF YOU HAVE
HEARD MARQUESA TESTIFY. SHE CAME
TO A NUMBER OF COMMITTEES LAST
YEAR, AND SHE IS AN ENTREPRENEUR
AND IMPACT INVESTOR WHO IS
FOCUSED ON ALTERNATIVE FINANCE
AND EQUITABLE ACCESS TO VENTURE
CAPITAL AND ENTREPRENEURSHIP.
SHE IS THE FOUNDER AND CEO OF
PERM, A MARKETPLACE FOR ANGEL
INVESTING THAT IS DESIGNED TO
CREATE GREATER ACCESS TO
GENERATIONAL WEALTH FOR BIPOC
AND OTHER COMMUNITIES WHO HAVE
HISTORICALLY BEEN EXCLUDED FROM
INVESTING OPPORTUNITIES.
MARQUESA FINCH IS ALSO A
FOUNDING MEMBER OF THE F FIVE
COLLECTIVE. CONGRATULATIONS.
CHIP IT OUT. AWAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. NOW, LET ME TURN IT OVER
TO MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN DIEGO.
THANK YOU. TO MY COLLEAGUE FROM
BERKELEY. I WANT TO INTRODUCE
OUR NEXT HONOREE. THIS IS DIVYA
REDDY. MISS REDDY IS AN
ENTREPRENEUR AND IMPACT
INVESTOR. SHE IS ALSO A FOUNDING
PARTNER OF THE F FIVE
COLLECTIVE, AS WELL AS THE
PRODUCT LEAD AND CHIEF
COMPLIANCE OFFICER AT PERINEUM.
MISS REDDY LEVERAGES HER
EXTENSIVE BACKGROUND IN BANKING
AND CAPITAL MARKETS TO MENTOR
EMERGING COMPANIES ON GROWTH AND
FUNDRAISING. SHE ALSO MENTORS
TECH INNOVATORS THROUGH
HARVARD'S DXB FOUNDRY. THANK
YOU, THANK YOU, THANK YOU SO
MUCH, MOORLACH.
THANK YOU. AND NEXT I'D LIKE TO
INTRODUCE ALLISON BYERS. SHE IS
THE FOUNDER OF SCROOBIUS, A TECH
COMPANY WORKING TO CHANGE THE
STARTUP LANDSCAPE BY FOSTERING
DIVERSITY THROUGH WIDESPREAD
CONNECTIONS AMONG FOUNDERS,
INVESTORS AND SERVICE PROVIDERS
VIA SCALABLE ONLINE EDUCATION
COMMUNITY AND DATA DRIVEN
CURATION. MISS BYERS IS A
CHAMPION FOR EQUITABLE CAPITAL
DISTRIBUTION. WITH OVER 20 YEARS
OF EXPERIENCE IN STARTUPS AND
THE TECH INDUSTRY. SHE USES HER
EXTENSIVE KNOWLEDGE TO BE A
CATALYST FOR CHANGE, ESPECIALLY
IN REGARDS TO GENDER BIAS AND
EMPOWERING MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES. MS. LET'S WELCOME
HER.
THANK YOU. AND NOW I'M GOING TO
PASS IT BACK OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE FROM BERKELEY. LAST
BUT NOT LEAST, DEREK MIXED BY
ALI DEREK ALI MIXED BY ALI, A
FOUR TIME GRAMMY WINNING
RECORDING AND MIXING ENGINEER
WHO HAS TURNED TECH ENTREPRENEUR
. HE HASN'T ABANDONED HIS MUSIC,
BUT HE IS ALSO A TECH
ENTREPRENEUR AND HE IS THE
FOUNDER OF ENGINEERS, A VERTICAL
SOFTWARE PLATFORM FOR ARTISTS,
AUDIO ENGINEERS, RECORDING
STUDIOS, PRODUCERS AND RECORD
LABELS. HE PROVIDES INNOVATIVE
SOLUTIONS FOR MUSIC PRODUCTION
PROFESSIONALS THAT REFLECT HIS
DEDICATION TO MENTORSHIP AND
COMMUNITY EMPOWERMENT. HE RUNS
WORKSHOPS THAT SHARE HIS
EXPERTISE AND TRAIN PEOPLE IN
HIS SKILLS ALL ACROSS THE
COUNTRY, AND THE WORLD.
COLLEAGUES. STARTUPS RUN BY
WOMEN AND PEOPLE OF COLOR ARE
OFTEN OVERLOOKED BY TRADITIONAL
VENTURE CAPITALIST FIRMS, AND
THEY HAVE MUCH MORE TROUBLE AS
I'VE MENTIONED IN THE BEGINNING,
FROM GETTING OFF THE GROUND.
FORTUNATELY THOSE WE'VE
INTRODUCED TO YOU TODAY WERE
ABLE TO DEFY THOSE OBSTACLES,
BUT THEY ARE RARE. THESE
INDIVIDUALS THAT STAND BEFORE US
TODAY ARE COMMITTED TO HELPING
LEVEL THE PLAYING FIELD AND
CHANGE THE BIASED, MALE
DOMINATED CULTURE IN THE
ENTREPRENEURIAL AND TECH
SECTORS. THEY HAVE BEEN FIERCE
ADVOCATES FOR LAST YEAR'S SB 54,
WHICH WE ALL PASSED AND THE
GOVERNOR SIGNED INTO LAW, WHICH
MANDATED ACCURATE DATA
COLLECTION ON VENTURE CAPITAL
ALLOCATION IN THE HOPES OF
FOSTERING ACCOUNTABILITY AND
PROMOTING PROGRESS. THE
INNOVATIVE COMPANIES THAT THEY
ALL REPRESENT ARE ELEVATING
STARTUPS FOUNDED BY PEOPLE OF
COLOR AND WOMEN, AND CREATING
PARTNERSHIPS THAT PROMOTE GROWTH
AND MUTUAL BENEFITS. BUT LET US
FIRST GIVE DEREK ALI HIS,
RESOLUTION, AND THEN I WILL
CLOSE AND THEN WE CAN DO OTHER
PHOTOS. HOW ABOUT THAT? THERE WE
GO. THANK YOU. WE CAN LEAVE THAT
. IT'S A GREAT SMILE. YES. YES.
THEY ALL ALL OF THOSE WHO WE'VE
GIVEN RESOLUTIONS TO TODAY ARE
JOINED BY THEIR PROUD FAMILIES
AND COLLEAGUES ON THE FLOOR AND
IN THE GALLERY. PLEASE JOIN ME
IN WELCOMING AND HONORING THESE
INCREDIBLE INDIVIDUALS. ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE, WE SAY WELCOME AND
CONGRATULATIONS TO OUR FIVE
AMAZING HONOREES. PICTURE ONE
JUST FOR YOU ALL. OKAY.
NOW IT'S YOUR TIME. IF OTHER
MEMBERS WANT TO JOIN IN ON THE
PHOTO.
AGAIN. ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE, WE SAY
CONGRATULATIONS TO OUR FIVE
HONOREES.
MEMBERS. WITHOUT OBJECTION, WE
WILL BE TAKING UP FILE ITEM
RESOLUTION. OUT OF ORDER FOR THE
FOLLOWING. I SHOULD SAY
RESOLUTION OUT OF ORDER. FILE
ITEM 31 SCR 12. SENATOR MIN, ARE
YOU PREPARED? HE IS SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ SENATE JOINT
RESOLUTION 12 BY SENATOR MIN.
RELATIVE TO OIL AND GAS LEASES.
SENATOR MANN THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. SGR 12 REQUESTS THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT REVISED
CURRENT BANKRUPTCY RULES TO
ENSURE THAT THE OIL INDUSTRY
CANNOT USE EXISTING RULES TO
PUSH THE COSTS OF
DECOMMISSIONING OIL AND GAS
WELLS ONTO STATE TAXPAYERS. AS
YOU ALL KNOW, IN 2021 WE HAD A
MAJOR OIL SPILL OFF THE COAST OF
HUNTINGTON BEACH, WHICH I
REPRESENT. THOSE RESPONSIBLE FOR
THAT SPILL ARE BEING HELD TO
ACCOUNT FINANCIALLY.
UNFORTUNATELY FURTHER UP THE
COAST, OTHER OPERATORS HAVE
FOUND IT IN THEIR BEST INTEREST
TO DECLARE BANKRUPTCY AND WALK
AWAY FROM DOZENS OF UNPLUGGED
OIL WELLS AND ASSOCIATED
EQUIPMENT AND INFRASTRUCTURE
WITH A $200 MILLION HIT TO THE
GENERAL FUND, RESULTING. THIS IS
UNFORTUNATELY PART OF AN
ESTABLISHED INDUSTRY MODEL WHERE
MAJOR OIL WELL PRODUCERS OR
OWNERS SELL THEIR WELLS TO AN
INDEPENDENT PRODUCER, WHO THEN
SELLS TO SMALLER ONE, AND SO ON.
UNTIL THE LAST COMPANY DECLARES
BANKRUPTCY. WALKING AWAY WITH
AND LEAVING STATE TAXPAYERS ON
THE HOOK FOR WHAT CAN BE
MULTI-MILLION DOLLAR, WELL,
CLEANUPS. THIS RESOLUTION ASKS
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO MAKE
SURE THAT AN OIL WELL BANKRUPTCY
WILL NOT ADVERSELY AFFECT
CALIFORNIA STATE TAXPAYERS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE
, ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE? HEARING
SEEING NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLAN EL RODIGO.
AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. BLAKE
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLI DODD. BARROSO AYE. EGGMAN.
AYE. GLASER GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE
HURTADO. AYE. JONES LAIRD. AYE.
LIMÓN AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE.
MENGIBAR AYE. MIN. AYE. NEWMAN
AYE. NGUYEN NILO. OKOBO PADILLA.
AYE. PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO AYE. SATO SKINNER. AYE.
SMALL. CUEVAS STERN. AYE.
UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER.
AYE. WILK. SECRETARY. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN
BECKER. DALLI DODD. GLASER
GROVE. NO JONES. NGUYEN. NILO
OKOBO. SATO SMALL. CUEVAS. AYE
WILK. AYE JONES. NO. IGE 29.
NOES TWO. THE MEASURE PASSES.
NOW, MEMBERS, WE'RE MOVING ON.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL
BE DEEMED READ MESSAGES FROM THE
ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED READ.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED. NOW WE'RE MOVING ON TO
MOTIONS, RESOLUTIONS AND
NOTICES. I WANT TO RECOGNIZE
SENATOR WIENER FOR MOTIONS.
UNDER MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. OH I THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES,
I MOVE ADOPTION OF AUTHORS,
AMENDMENTS FOR BUDGET BILLS AND
BUDGET TRAILER BILLS THAT CROSS
THE DESK ON FRIDAY, SATURDAY AND
SUNDAY, JUNE 7TH TO NINTH, 2024,
THESE AMENDMENTS WILL BE
ADOPTED, PUBLISHED, AND THE BILL
IS RETURNED TO THE COMMITTEE.
SENATOR NEAL, FOR WHAT PURPOSE?
TO OBJECT AND RECOMMEND THAT A
NO VOTE. SENATOR CABALLERO I'M
JUST WAITING TO KNOW I'M NOT
GETTING IN THE MIDDLE OF THIS
FIGHT, BUT I JUST HAVE A BILL
I'D LIKE TO PULL OFF IT WHEN THE
TIME IS APPROPRIATE. ALL RIGHT.
SENATOR, SENATOR, MEMBERS,
MEMBERS WERE TRYING TO CALL THE
ROLL. SENATOR WIENER IS ASKING
FOR A AYE VOTE. SENATOR NEIL IS
ASKING FOR A NO VOTE. NO VOTE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I'LL RODA-GIL. AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. BLAKE
SPURR. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLI. NO. DODD. BARRASSO AYE.
EGGMAN. AYE. GLASER GONZALEZ.
AYE. GROVE. NO OR DATO. AYE.
JONES. NO LAIRD. AYE. LIMÓN.
MCGUIRE. AYE. MENGIBAR. AYE
MINH. AYE. NEWMAN AYE. NGUYEN.
NO. NILO NO. OCHOA. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. AYE. RUBIO
AYE. SATO. NO SKINNER. AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE. STERN.
AYE. UMBERG. AYE WAHAB. AYE.
WIENER. AYE. WILK NO. AYES 27.
NOS. SEVEN MOTION TO AMEND IS
ADOPTED. OUR NOW MEMBERS. IT'S
TIME. IF ANY MEMBER WANTS TO
REMOVE AN ITEM FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. NOW WOULD BE THE TIME.
SENATOR. MEN, THANK YOU, MISTER
PRESIDENT. ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LOWE, I'D LIKE TO REQUEST
TO REMOVE AB 996 FROM THE
ENACTED FILE. THIS WILL NOTE
SENATOR NGUYEN, THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I WOULD LIKE TO
REQUEST TO REMOVE ITEM A, DASH
SIX SCR 103 FROM THE ACTIVE
FILE. THANK YOU, THANK YOU. THE
JUST WILL NOTE, SENATOR
CABALLERO. MR. PRESIDENT, I RISE
TO REMOVE FILE ITEM A2 TWO SR 44
FROM THE INACTIVE FILE. THANK
YOU. THE DESK WILL NOTE SENATOR
NEWMAN. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I'D LIKE TO REQUEST
TO PULL AB 1953 FROM THE CONSENT
FILE AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR. THE DESK WILL NOTE
SENATOR SKINNER. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BONTA, PLEASE MOVE. ITEM
A 22 AB 1186 FROM THE INACTIVE
FILE. THANK YOU, THANK YOU. THE
DESK WILL NOTE. ANY OTHER
MEMBERS WISHING TO MOVE A ITEM
FROM ACTIVE TO INACTIVE FILE?
SEEING NONE. NOW WE'LL MOVE ON
TO. ALL RIGHT. MEMBERS, PURSUANT
TO SENATE RULE 29.10, SEE. THE
FOLLOWING BILLS ARE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON RULES. FILE
ITEM 20 AB 347. PURSUANT TO
SENATE RULE 20 9-10, BE THE
FOLLOWING BILLS ARE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEES ON RULES FILE
ITEM 21 AB 1768. NOW, MEMBERS,
WE'RE MOVING ON TO CONSIDERATION
OF A DAILY FILE. SECOND READING
FILE ITEMS 1 TO 23. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 960
WITH AMENDMENTS 2046 WITH
AMENDMENTS 20, 51, 23, 70, 24,
29, 23, 99, 23, OH TWO, 25, 93
WITH AMENDMENTS 2684, WITH
AMENDMENTS 457, WITH AMENDMENTS
805, WITH AMENDMENTS 2199, WITH
AMENDMENTS 3090 H.J.R. 12 AB
1916 WITH AMENDMENTS AB. 1943,
WITH AMENDMENTS 2556, WITH
AMENDMENTS 2250, WITH AMENDMENTS
2146, WITH AMENDMENTS 347, 1768,
1941, 2301. SECOND READING IS
DEEMED READ NOW. MEMBERS, WE'RE
MOVING TO GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENTS. SENATOR GROVE,
SHE'S PREPARED. WE HAVE TWO
ITEMS FILED. ITEM 25 AND 26.
SENATOR GROVE, THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES, FILE ITEM NUMBER 25
IS A CONFIRMATION OF LOU PAULSEN
TO THE REAPPOINTMENT OF THE
PUBLIC EMPLOYEE RELATIONS BOARD
PRIOR TO HIS INITIAL APPOINTMENT
IN THE BOARD OF 2019, MR.
PAULSEN SERVED FOR 14 YEARS AS
THE PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS DÍAS
AND THE CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA
FIRE FOUNDATION. HE WAS APPROVED
ON THE AT THE RULES COMMITTEE ON
MAY 29TH ON A50 VOTE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE, ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS APPOINTMENT.
HEARING. SEEING NONE. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLAN.
ALVARADO. GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA
AYE. ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS AYE.
BECKER. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ AYE. DALLI. AYE. DODD
BARRASSO. AYE. EGGMAN AYE.
GLAZER. GONZALEZ GROVE. AYE.
HURTADO AYE. JONES. AYE. LAIRD
AYE. LEMON MCGUIRE. AYE.
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN AYE. NILO AYE.
OCHOA. PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO.
AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO AYE. SATO.
AYE. SKINNER. AYE SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. AYE. STERN AYE. UMBER.
AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER. AYE.
WILK AYE. AYES 33 NOES ZERO. THE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED. NOW
WE'RE MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM 26.
SENATOR GROVE. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES, FILE ITEM
NUMBER 26 IS THE CONFIRMATION OF
CHIEF DANIEL BERLANT AS THE
STATE FIRE MARSHAL FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF FORESTRY AND FIRE
PROTECTION. CHIEF BERLANT HAS
OVER 20 YEARS OF SERVICE WITH
CAL FIRE. PRIOR TO HIS
APPOINTMENT, HE WAS A DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT'S
COMMUNITY WILDFIRE MITIGATION
AND PREPAREDNESS DIVISION. CHIEF
BERLANT TOOK A LOT OF SERIOUS
AND PRETTY TOUGH QUESTIONS FROM
THE RULES COMMITTEE REGARDING
THE OVERLAY OF OUR FIRE PRONE
AREAS AND THE MITIGATION
STANDARDS THAT NEED TO BE DONE
IN ORDER TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
COMMUNITIES IN THE RURAL
MOUNTAIN AREAS WHERE WE'RE FIRE
PRONE AREAS HAVE THE ABILITY TO
GET INSURANCE. AND HE IS WORKING
DIRECTLY WITH THE INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT THOSE CONSTITUENTS IN
CALIFORNIA THAT LIVE IN RURAL
AREAS HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO GET
INSURANCE FOR THEIR HOMES AND
NOT AT A HUGE PRICE, BUT THEY
CAN DO THINGS THAT WILL MITIGATE
SOME OF THAT COST. HE ALSO IS
VERY MUCH INFORMED ON THE SECOND
CHANCERS WORKING WITH THE C.C.C,
SO THAT THOSE INDIVIDUALS THAT
ARE EXITING THE PRISON SYSTEM
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO GET A JOB
THAT WILL TEACH THEM SOFT
SKILLS, ALLOW THEM TO DEVELOP A
SKILL AND A TALENT, AND BE ABLE
TO BE ELEVATED TO THE NEXT
POSITION OF A FULL FIREFIGHTER
POSITION. SO HE'S GOT A GREAT
PERSPECTIVE. HE'S WIDELY, WIDELY
RESPECTED AND RESPECTFULLY ASKED
FOR AN AYE VOTE. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
APPOINTMENT? HEARING? SEEING
NONE. SECRETARY, YOU MAY CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN ALVARADO GILL.
AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. BLAKESBERG
AYE. BRADFORD. AYE. CORTEZ
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLI. AYE. DODD BARRASSO. AYE.
EGGMAN AYE. GLASER GONZALEZ.
GROVE AYE. HURTADO AYE. JONES.
AYE. LAIRD AYE. LEMON. MCGUIRE
AYE. MENGIBAR. AYE. MEN NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN. AYE. NILO OKOBO.
PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH AYE. RUBIO AYE. SATO. AYE.
SKINNER AYE. SMALL. CUEVAS AYE.
STERN. AYE. UMBERG AYE. WAHAB
AYE. WIENER. AYE. WILK AYE.
SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALAN BECKER.
DODD GLAZER. GONZALEZ. LIMON
MIN. AYE NILO. AYE. AYE
AQUEBOGUE. AYES 33. NO. ZERO.
THE APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED.
AND NOW WE'RE MOVING ON TO
SENATE. THIRD READING. WE HAVE
FILE ITEM 41. SENATOR ASHBY IS
PREPARED. SECRETARY, YOU MAY
READ. SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION 154 BY SENATOR ASHBY
RELATIVE TO CALIFORNIA AEROSPACE
DAY. SENATOR ASHBY, THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
I RISE TO PRESENT SCR 154, WHICH
DESIGNATES JUNE 5TH AS AEROSPACE
DAY AND RECOGNIZES THE
CONTRIBUTIONS OF CALIFORNIA'S
AEROSPACE INDUSTRIES. OUR
AEROSPACE INDUSTRY SUPPORTS MORE
THAN 500,000 HIGH PAYING JOBS,
GENERATES MORE THAN $100 BILLION
IN ANNUAL ECONOMIC ACTIVITY AND
GENERATES $7 BILLION IN STATE
AND LOCAL TAXES. CALIFORNIA'S
HOME TO THREE NASA RESEARCH AND
ENGINEERING CENTERS ONE IN
MOUNTAIN VIEW, ONE IN EDWARDS
AND ONE IN PASADENA. MANY OTHER
KEY SITES OF AEROSPACE ACTIVITY
CALL CALIFORNIA HOME, INCLUDING
RIGHT HERE IN SENATE DISTRICT
EIGHT. THE AEROSPACE MUSEUM OF
CALIFORNIA SITS ON THE GROUNDS
OF THE FORMER MCCLELLAN AIR
FORCE BASE, NOW KNOWN AS
MCCLELLAN BUSINESS PARK. THE
MUSEUM FOCUSES ON DELIVERING
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS IN SCIENCE,
TECHNOLOGY, ENGINEERING, AND
MATH TO OVER 30,000 STUDENTS
EACH YEAR. INSPIRE OUR FUTURE
LEADERS TO PURSUE A CAREER IN
STEM. CALIFORNIA SETS THE
STANDARD FOR PROGRESS. OUR
SCIENTISTS, ENGINEERS, AND
INNOVATORS LEAD THE NATION IN
DEVELOPING NEW TECHNOLOGIES,
INCLUDING UNMANNED BATTERY
POWERED AIRCRAFTS, SPACECRAFT
DESIGN, COMMERCIAL SATELLITE
ADVANCEMENTS, NAVIGATION
SYSTEMS, AND, OF COURSE,
ADVANCED ROBOTICS. TOGETHER, WE
CAN ENSURE THAT OUR STATE
CONTINUES TO LEAD IN THE
INNOVATION BY INCREASING
AWARENESS OF CALIFORNIA'S
AEROSPACE CONTRIBUTIONS. PLEASE
JOIN ME IN DESIGNATING JUNE 5TH
AS CALIFORNIA AEROSPACE DAY BY
VOTING AYE ON SCR ONE FIVE. FOR
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. SENATOR GROVE,
PRESIDENT, I TOO RISE IN SUPPORT
OF SCR 154 HAVING A THE MOJAVE
AIR AND SPACE PORT IN MY
DISTRICT. YOU KNOW, THINK ABOUT
THAT IN THE MIDDLE OF A DESERT.
WE HAVE A SPACEPORT WHERE VIRGIN
ATLANTIC OPERATES, WHERE THE
SPACESHIP ONE IS OPERATED, WHERE
MANY THINGS HAVE BEEN TESTED AND
PROVEN TO BE A VALUE TO THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
REGARDING THE SPACE PROGRAM IN
MY DISTRICT, IT DOES EMPLOY
QUITE A BIT OF PEOPLE, IT IS AN
INCREDIBLE SIGHT TO SEE WHEN YOU
GO OUT THERE AND YOU SEE SOME OF
THE TECHNOLOGY AND THE THINGS
THAT ARE GOING ON, AND WE'RE
PRODUCING THAT RIGHT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. SO RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
SENATOR PORTANTINO. THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. MEMBERS, I RISE
TO STRONGLY SUPPORT SCR 154 AS
THE DISTRICT THAT HAS JET
PROPULSION LABORATORY PROUDLY IN
THE CENTER OF IT WITH SPIRIT
OPPORTUNITY, ALL OF THOSE
WONDERFUL MARS ROVERS, VOYAGER
AND MANY, MANY, EXCITING CUTTING
EDGE PROJECTS AND A LONG TIME,
EARTH SCIENCES DIVISION THAT HAS
BEEN MAPPING GLOBAL WARMING AND
PROVIDING WONDERFUL, TECHNICAL
ADVICE TO THE GREAT STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS, BUT I DO WANT TO MAKE ONE
NOTATION THAT MY CONSTITUENTS
WOULD CHASTISE ME IF I DID NOT
CORRECT JET PROPULSION
LABORATORY IS PHYSICALLY LOCATED
IN THE CITY OF LA CANADA
FLINTRIDGE, THOUGH IT HAS A
PASADENA POST OFFICE AND
ADDRESS. SO I DO WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE PROUD FOLKS OF LA
CANADA GET THEIR DUE. THANKS.
THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM? SENATOR ASHBY, WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE? I SHOULD HAVE
MENTIONED THAT, YES. I URGE AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. MEMBERS
THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLLCALL. IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
TO USING A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL
ON THIS ITEM? HEARING SEEING.
NONE. AYES 32, NOES ZERO. THE
MEASURE PASSES. NOW MEMBERS,
IT'S. WE'RE MOVING TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. NOW IS THE
TIME FOR ANY MEMBER WISHING TO
REMOVE AN ITEM FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR TO DO SO. NOW HEARING
SEEING NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ ALL ITEMS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR AND SPECIAL CONSENT.
ASSEMBLY BILL 1924, 25, 3628,
1226, 34, 2748, 1939, 22, 68,
32, 62. ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION 163 168, ONE 7174,
181, 186, 190 111 97. RIGHT
MEMBERS, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. ALLEN I'LL
RODA-GIL I ARCHULETA. ASHBY I
ATKINS, I BECKER. BLAKE SPEER I
BRADFORD I CABALLERO I CORTEZ I
DALLY I DODD TERRAZZO I EGGMAN
GLAZER. GONZALEZ. GROVE I
HURTADO I JONES I LAIRD I LIMÓN
MCGUIRE I MENGIBAR I MEN I
NEWMAN I NGUYEN I NILO I OKOBO
PADILLA I PORTANTINO I ROTH I
RUBIO I SATO I SKINNER I SMALL
RIVAS I STERN I UMBER I WAHAB I
WIENER I WILK I. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN ARCHULETA. BECKER. DODD
EGGMAN I GLAZER. GONZALEZ.
LAMONE OCHOA. AYES 32 NOES ZERO
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR. AYES
32. NOES ZERO ON THE SPECIAL
CONSENT CALENDAR. NOW MEMBERS,
WE'RE RETURNING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. NOW IS THE TIME FOR
ADJOURNMENT MEMORIES. WE HAVE.
SENATOR CORTEZ. FIRST UP. IS HE
PREPARED? SENATOR CORTEZ, THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I RISE TO ADJOURN IN
MEMORY OF TIM QUIGLEY JUNIOR,
WHO PASSED AWAY ON MARCH 15TH AT
THE AGE OF 78. TODAY WITH US IN
THE GALLERY IS WE HAVE TIM'S
SON, AARON QUIGLEY, DAUGHTER IN
LAW, JENNY QUIGLEY, AND TWO OF
HIS GRANDCHILDREN, MARA AND
BRIDGET. I WANT TO THANK THEM
ALL FOR TRAVELING FROM SANTA
CLARA COUNTY TO JOIN US TODAY.
AND OF COURSE, I AND SO MANY
OTHERS ARE SORRY FOR YOUR
TREMENDOUS LOSS. IT'S OUR LOSS
AS WELL. KNOWN AFFECTIONATELY AS
TIM, HE WAS A CHERISHED FATHER,
GRANDFATHER, BROTHER, UNCLE AND
FRIEND. HIS LIFE WAS DEFINED BY
HIS COMMITMENT TO HIS FAMILY,
COMMUNITY AND HIS COUNTRY. HE
WAS VERY, VERY COMMITTED TO HIS
FORM OF PUBLIC SERVICE. HE WAS
BORN IN WABASHA, MINNESOTA IN
1945. HE GRADUATED FROM THE US
NAVAL ACADEMY, US NAVAL ACADEMY
IN 1967, AND EMBARKED ON A
NEARLY 30 YEAR CAREER IN THE
NAVY. HOPING I CAN HAVE
ATTENTION, MR. PRESIDENT, THIS
IS A DISTINGUISHED VETERAN AND A
GREAT LEADER, NOT JUST FOR MY
AREA, BUT FOR THE ENTIRE
COUNTRY. AFTER HIS 30 YEAR
CAREER IN THE NAVY, HE SERVED AS
A P-3 PILOT UNDER, TOOK THREE
COMBAT TOURS DURING THE VIETNAM
WAR AND HELD SEVERAL SENIOR
LEADERSHIP POSITIONS IN THE
MILITARY. HE FOUND HIS WAY TO
SAN JOSE DURING HIS NAVAL CAREER
, A CITY THAT WOULD BECOME HIS
HOME FOR NEARLY 50 YEARS. IN
ADDITION TO ATTENDING THE US
NAVAL ACADEMY, HE ALSO GRADUATED
FROM THE JOHN F KENNEDY SCHOOL
OF GOVERNMENT, HARVARD
UNIVERSITY, AND HE WAS A FORMER
COURSE PRESIDENT AT THE NATO
DEFENSE COLLEGE FROM 1991 TO
1992. AFTER RETIRING FROM THE
NAVY AS A CAPTAIN IN 1994, HE
RETURNED TO SAN JOSE TO PURSUE A
CAREER AS A CORPORATE NONPROFIT
EXECUTIVE. HE HELD POSITIONS
SUCH AS CEO OF THE SILICON
VALLEY DEFENSE AND SPACE
CONSORTIUM, THE CEO OF THE
SILICON VALLEY GLOBAL TRADING
CENTER, THE PROGRAM DIRECTOR OF
GREEN CHANGE CALIFORNIA, WHICH
IS THE PLACE I FIRST MET TIM. HE
WAS HIGHLY ENGAGED IN THE
COMMUNITY, SERVING AS A BOARD
MEMBER FOR BOTH THE SAN JOSE
SYMPHONY AND ALSO THE SAN JOSE
POLICE FOUNDATION. HIS REGULAR
PRESENCE AT LOCAL GOVERNMENT
MEETINGS AND COMMUNITY EVENTS
EARNED HIM THE REPUTATION OF A
RESPECTED CIVIC LEADER, KNOWN
FOR HIS TIRELESS COMMITMENT AND
BOUNDLESS ENERGY. TIM'S REAL
CLAIM TO FAME AS I GOT TO KNOW
HIM IN THE PLACE I THINK HE WAS
MOST COMFORTABLE WITH, SISTER
CITIES INTERNATIONAL. ON MARCH
14TH OF THIS YEAR, SISTER CITIES
INTERNATIONAL MOURNED HIS LOSS
AS A REMARKABLE MEMBER OF OUR
COMMUNITY. HE HAD BEEN CHAIRMAN
OF THE HONORARY BOARD OF
DIRECTORS, CHAIRMAN EMERITUS,
GLOBAL ENVOY AND FIRST CHAIRMAN
OF THE SISTER CITIES
INTERNATIONAL FOUNDATION. HE
LEFT AN INCREDIBLE MARK ON THAT
ORGANIZATION. HE SERVED AS
COUNTRY REPRESENTATIVE TO
AUSTRALIA, IRELAND, ITALY, SAUDI
ARABIA, TAIWAN AND UKRAINE, AS
WELL AS REGIONAL REPRESENTATIVE
TO NORTH AFRICA AND THE MIDDLE
EAST AND INTERNATIONAL
ORGANIZATION REPRESENTATIVE TO
NATO. HIS CONTRIBUTIONS WERE
INVALUABLE IN TRIBUTE TO TIM'S
LEGACY, MICHAEL HYATT, THE CHAIR
EMERITUS OF SISTER CITIES
INTERNATIONAL, AND KEVIN
O'DONNELL, THE COUNTRY
REPRESENTATIVE LIAISON, SPOKE
VERY, VERY ELOQUENTLY ABOUT
TIM'S ENDURING LEGACY, HIS LONG
TERM LEGACY IN TERMS OF
INTERNATIONAL RELATIONS AND
PEACE DURING THAT THAT MEMORIAL
ON MARCH 14TH, I GOT TO KNOW HIM
THERE AS A MEMBER OF THE SISTER
CITIES INTERNATIONAL BOARD.
MYSELF AND TO SEE TIM IN ACTION,
HE WAS TRULY A GLOBAL LEADER,
NOT JUST IN WORDS, BUT IN DEEDS.
HE WAS A VERY, VERY CLOSE FRIEND
OF FORMER THE LATE FORMER
SECRETARY NORMAN Y. MINETA, WHO
WAS ONE OF THE FOUNDERS OF
SISTER CITIES IN THE SAN JOSE
AREA. TIM, IS GOING TO BE SORELY
MISSED. HE ALREADY IS, HIS SON,
AARON, AGAIN, WHO'S IN THE
GALLERY? AND I TALK ABOUT HIM
FREQUENTLY. I RECEIVED MORE SAU
TEXT MESSAGES AND EMAIL MESSAGES
AFTER HIS PASSING THAN ANYONE IN
MY LIFETIME AFTER THEIR PASSING,
INCLUDING MY OWN FAMILY MEMBERS.
HIS LEGACY OF SERVICE LIVES ON.
HE, HIS SON AARON, WHO I'VE
MENTIONED A COUPLE OF TIMES, IS
ONE OF OUR LEADERS AT THE SANTA
CLARA VALLEY TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY. TIM'S SERVICE WAS AN
INSPIRATION TO MANY. I KNOW IT
WILL CONTINUE TO BE AN
INSPIRATION TO HIS SON, TO THE
FAMILY MEMBERS WHO ARE HERE, WHO
ARE HERE, AND TO THE EXTENDED
FAMILY AS WELL. HE IS SURVIVED.
TIM IS SURVIVED BY HIS PARTNER,
KIYOSHI, HIS FIVE SIBLINGS, FOUR
CHILDREN, SEVEN GRANDCHILDREN
AND A GREAT GRANDCHILD. AND
AGAIN, HE'S ALREADY BEEN DEARLY
MISSED AND HE WILL CONTINUE TO
BE. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU. ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE, WE
EXTEND OUR DEEPEST CONDOLENCES
TO THE QUIGLEY FAMILY AND ASK
THAT YOU BRING HIS NAME FORWARD
SO HE CAN BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED. MEMORIALIZED. NEXT
UP IS SENATOR PORTANTINO.
MEMBERS, I RISE TODAY. SADLY TO
ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF RAUL
PORTO. AFTER IMMIGRATING FROM
MANZANILLA, CUBA, IN SEARCH OF A
BETTER LIFE, HE SETTLED IN LOS
ANGELES, WHERE ALL IN HIS LATE
WIFE ROSA, WHO WAS ALSO A BAKER
AND CO-FOUNDER OF THEIR
WONDERFUL BAKERY, WHICH THEY
STARTED THEIR CHAIN IN 1976.
TOGETHER THEY HELPED GENERATIONS
OF CUBAN, CUBAN IMMIGRANTS FIND
A TASTE OF HOME AND POPULARIZE
REGIONAL SPECIALTIES SUCH AS
STUFFED AND FRIED POTATO BALLS
AND PRESSED CUBAN SANDWICHES.
LATER ON, THE PORTO'S EXPANDED
THEIR BUSINESS BEYOND CUBAN
PASTRIES TO SERVE TREATS THAT
APPEALED TO A NUMBER OF
CULTURES, INCLUDING, DANISHES,
FRUIT TARTS, MUFFINS, AND MANY,
MANY MORE. IN 1982, PORTO'S
RELOCATED TO GLENDALE AND
EVENTUALLY FURTHER EXPANDED TO
BURBANK AND BUENA PARK, WEST
COVINA AND NORTHRIDGE. KNOWN FOR
HIS HUMBLE NATURE, RAUL BALANCED
HIS ROLES AS A DEVOTED HUSBAND,
FATHER, AND BUSINESSMAN,
INSPIRING ALL WHO KNEW HIM WITH
HIS PASSION AND HIS COMMITMENT
IN HIS LATER YEARS, OUR WOOL
FOUND IMMENSE JOY IN SPENDING
TIME WITH HIS GRANDCHILDREN AND
WATCHING THE NEXT GENERATION OF
HIS FAMILY GROW AND EXCEL. RAUL
AND ROSA ARE SURVIVED BY
SURVIVED BY GENERATIONS OF
PORTO'S, INCLUDING MANY
GRANDCHILDREN. THEIR THREE
CHILDREN BEATRICE, RAUL JR AND
MARGARITA, ALL GREW UP HELPING
THEIR PARENTS IN THE BAKERY AND
WENT ON TO RUN THE BUSINESSES
THEMSELVES. HE HAD A TREMENDOUS
LOVE FOR FAMILY AND TRULY AN
AMERICAN SUCCESS STORY, AN
AMERICAN DREAM. HE CAME HERE TO
PURSUE A BETTER LIFE FOR HIS
FAMILY, AND THROUGH HIS HARD
WORK AND PERSEVERANCE, HE
CREATED THAT WORK, PASSED IT ON
TO HIS CHILDREN. BEATRICE IS A
FIXTURE IN GLENDALE. I JUST WAS
AT AN EVENT THE OTHER DAY IN
BURBANK AND THERE WAS THE PORTO
FAMILY DONATING FOOD TO SUPPORT
THE COMMUNITY. THIS IS A FAMILY
THAT CAME HERE TO DO GOOD THINGS
, SUCCEED, AND TURN THAT SUCCESS
INTO COMMUNITY SERVICE. AND I
PROUDLY STAND TO ASK THIS BODY
TO ADJOURN IN HIS MEMORY. PLEASE
SEND OUR CONDOLENCES TO THE
FAMILY AND BRING HIS NAME
FORWARD TO THE DESK. SENATOR
DURAZZO, I'M SORRY I DIDN'T SEE
YOU WERE GOING TO SPEAK. I JUST
WANT TO ADD A COUPLE OF, WORDS
TO WHAT MY COLLEAGUE SAID, THE
FIRST LOCATION OF THE PORTO'S
BAKERIES WAS IN ECHO PARK. MY
DISTRICT, WHICH IS HOME TO
THOUSANDS OF CUBAN REFUGEES. AND
I JUST WANT TO THANK THE PORTO
FAMILY BECAUSE OF THEIR CIVIC
AND THEIR BUSINESS CONTRIBUTIONS
TO LOS ANGELES, AND END BY
TELLING YOU THAT THE LINES AT
THE PORTO BAKERY ARE LONG. ALL
DAY INTO THE EVENING AND LEAVE
YOU WITH THIS THOUGHT WAWA CHEEZ
DOODLES, POTATO BALLS, TRES
LECHES, PLATEAU DE LECHON, ROPA
VIEJA, EMPANADAS AND OF COURSE,
THE CORTADITO COFFEE. THANK YOU.
PLEASE BRING HIS NAME FORWARD TO
THE DESK SO HE CAN BE
APPROPRIATELY MEMORIALIZED. AND
SENATOR BRADFORD, THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. TODAY I RISE IN
THE MEMORY OF A GREAT
CALIFORNIAN, A GREAT TEXAN AND A
GREAT AMERICAN, THAT IN THE
PERSON OF JAMES JOHNSON, WHO WAS
AN AMAZING SON, BROTHER, HUSBAND
, FATHER AND GRANDFATHER, MR.
JOHNSON WAS BORN IN TEXAS, IN
CLARKSVILLE, TEXAS, AND HE WAS
THE FIFTH OF SEVEN CHILDREN BORN
TO HIS LATE PARENTS, GEORGE AND
WILLIE MAE JOHNSON. AND AS EVEN
AS A YOUNG CHILD, HE WAS KNOWN
AS BEING A MASTERFUL STORY
TELLER, ENGAGING FOLKS IN ALL
KINDS OF STORIES, REYES AND
ACCOLADES AND JUST AMAZING
PERSON TO KNOW. MR. JOHNSON WAS
ALSO A VETERAN. HE SERVED IN THE
NAVY AND HE DID TWO TOURS OF
DUTY, AND HE WAS STATIONED IN
JAPAN. AND WHILE STATIONED IN
JAPAN, MR. JOHNSON OPTED NOT TO
STAY ON BASE AND TO LIVE IN THE
COMMUNITY SO HE COULD GET
IMMERSED IN THE CULTURE BOTH HE
AND HIS FAMILY. MR. JOHNSON,
DURING HIS LIFE VISITED OVER 32
COUNTRIES AND HE ENCOURAGED HIS
FAMILY TO EXPLORE AND EXPERIENCE
THE WORLD AS WELL. WHAT MAKES
MR. JOHNSON SO SPECIAL TO ME? AS
A YOUNG KID, HIS FAMILY WAS THE
SECOND AFRICAN AMERICAN FAMILY
TO MOVE ON MY STREET. AS A YOUNG
KID, AND HE MOVED THERE WITH HIS
LATE WIFE, MILDRED, AND HIS FOUR
DAUGHTERS, FRANCES, JEAN,
ANNETTE, YOLANDA AND CARLA. MR.
JOHNSON WAS THE ORIGINAL GIRL
DAD AND EVEN THOUGH THERE WAS
NOT A SINGLE BOY FOR ME TO PLAY
WITH AS A YOUNG KID, WE WELCOMED
HIM NONETHELESS BECAUSE MR.
JOHNSON WAS ALWAYS THERE
ENCOURAGING ALL OF US REGARDLESS
IF WE WERE BOYS OR GIRLS, TO BE
THE BEST THAT WE COULD BE, AS
STATED, THEY WERE THE SECOND
BLACK FAMILY ON OUR STREET. WE
HAVE LIVED ACROSS THE STREET
FROM EACH OTHER FOR 55 YEARS.
MR. JOHNSON. ALWAYS SHARED HIS
WISDOM AND ENCOURAGED MANY YOUNG
PEOPLE AND ADULTS TO BE THE BEST
THAT THEY COULD BE IN OUR
COMMUNITY, HE WAS WELL RESPECTED
AND ALWAYS EAGER TO HELP PEOPLE
BECOME THE BEST OF THEMSELVES
WITH INTEGRITY AND PURPOSE. I
STAND HERE TODAY BECAUSE OF THE
MANY DISCUSSIONS AND
ENCOURAGEMENT THAT HE GAVE ME
DURING MY THE CHALLENGES OF
BECOMING AN ELECTED OFFICIAL,
BEING INVOLVED IN THE COMMUNITY,
AND HE WAS ALWAYS QUICK TO SAY,
PUT A SIGN IN MY YARD. I NEVER
HAD TO ASK THEM. HE WOULD JUST
SAY MANY TIMES, WHERE IS MY
SIGN? AND THAT'S WHO MR. JOHNSON
WAS AGAIN. HE SERVED IN THE
MILITARY, BUT AFTER RETIRING
FROM THE MILITARY, HE WORKED FOR
THE US POSTAL SERVICE, NORRIS
INDUSTRIES, AND HE RETIRED FROM
REYNOLDS METALS. AGAIN. HE WAS A
CALM AND QUIET, BUT COMMANDING
AND RESPECTED INDIVIDUAL.
WHENEVER HE ENTERED A ROOM OR
ANY DISCUSSION. I'M BLESSED TO
HAVE KNOWN HIM FOR THE LAST 55
YEARS, AND THOUGH HIS PRESENCE
WILL BE GREATLY MISSED, HIS
LEGACY WILL LIVE ON THROUGH THE
MANY LIVES HE'S TOUCHED HIS FOUR
AMAZING DAUGHTERS, HIS
GRANDKIDS, AND NOW GREAT
GRANDKIDS. MEMBERS, I ASK YOU TO
JOIN IN MEMORY THE, ADJOURN IN
MEMORY OF JAMES JOHNSON. THANK
YOU. SENATOR, PLEASE ACCEPT THE
SENATE. CONDOLENCES TO THE
FAMILY AND THE FRIENDS. AND
PLEASE BRING HIS NAME FORWARD TO
THE DESK SO HE CAN BE
APPROPRIATELY MEMORIALIZED IF
THERE IS NO OTHER BUSINESS.
SENATOR MCGUIRE, THE DESK IS
CLEAR. THANK YOU SO MUCH, MADAM
PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES, I JUST
WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT BEFORE WE
ADJOURN TODAY TO BE ABLE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE WHAT WE DID IN THE
BEGINNING IS THE 80TH
ANNIVERSARY OF D-DAY IN
NORMANDY, FRANCE. 150,000
MEMBERS OF OUR BRAVE ALLIED
TROOPS JOINED TOGETHER IN THE
LARGEST SEABORNE INVASION IN
MILITARY HISTORY. 4000 DIED ON
THAT FIRST DAY DEFENDING OUR
DEMOCRACY AND OUR FREEDOMS AND
ALL THOSE WHO CONTINUE TO SERVE
THIS NATION IN OUR VETERANS,
INCLUDING THOSE WHO SERVE THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA. THE GREAT
SENATORS FROM PICO RIVERA,
STOCKTON, BAKERSFIELD, SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY, FULLERTON,
RIVERSIDE AND SANTA ANA. WE
THANK YOU, MEMBERS. ENJOY YOUR
FRIENDS, YOUR FAMILIES, ALL THE
DISTRICT EVENTS THIS WEEK. IN
THE NEXT FLOOR SESSION IS
SCHEDULED FOR MONDAY, JUNE 10TH
AT 2 P.M. THE SENATE WILL BE IN
RECESS UNTIL 3:30 P.M, AT WHICH
TIME THE ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL
BE MADE. WE WILL RECONVENE
MONDAY, JUNE 10TH AT 2 P.M.